that's me and that's my son Eleanor
Dreier knows everything about the threat
of measles she's a doctor
and a mother and her son caught the
potentially fatal disease when he was
just 10 months old after five days of
fever he had a rash in he was really
really unwell and he was then unwell for
another ten days before he was well
enough to go back to nursery dr. Greger
Blaine's deliberate misinformation
spread on social media I blame people
that are peddling misinformation to
those parents I don't believe that
anyone who doesn't vaccinate their child
is doing it to be willfully difficult I
believe that parents are fearful that
something is going to happen to their
child because they've given them a
vaccination dr. Dre Gia's son is now a
fit and healthy 12 year old but measles
has reemerged as a danger and the number
of childhood vaccinations being
administered is falling in 2018-19 there
was a drop in the uptake of all thirteen
routine childhood vaccinations in
England including diphtheria tetanus
polio and meningitis in 2017 18 to save
over 91 percent of children had the
first dose of the MMR vaccine a year
later that had dropped to just over 90
percent for the second MMR dose eighty
seven point two percent of children were
vaccinated by their fifth birthday in
2017 18 a year later that figure was
eighty six point four percent the UK
lost its measles free status in August
widely discredited anti vaccination
propaganda is to blame parent
complacency o access to health services
and itinerant populations are also
factors I think we can get to the 95
percent target we know what we need to
do we need to ensure that parents have
ready access to vaccination they often
need reminding to go particularly for
the later vaccines
in August Boris Johnson called on
parents to ignore superstitious
mumbo-jumbo spread on social media he
also said he was considering mandatory
vaccinations something health secretary
Matt Hancock repeated today almost
eradicated but now on the increase these
childhood diseases can be prevented from
spreading if parents choose to inoculate
ashes Joshi's Sky News